die gefahr ist eigentlich großen ganzen
südwesten amerikas kommt dafür ist diese
extreme hitzewelle die wirklich in die
rekordbücher bereits eingegangen ist
vor wenigen tagen wurde im death valley
im tal des todes in kalifornien die
möglicherweise heißt es die temperatur
aller zeiten gemessen mit 54,4 grad
celsius und diese hitzewelle führt
natürlich zu extrem gefährlichen
bedingungen und waldbrände drohen jetzt
auch in anderen bundesstaaten wie
arizona und nevada wo es besonders heiß
ist es denn ein ende dieser hitzewelle
abzusehen
bisher sagen die meteorologen
das ist die parole durchhalten gibt für
die bewohner dieser bundesstaat müssen
ja mehr als 40 millionen menschen
betroffen von dieser extremen hitzewelle
auch in las vegas der gambler paradies
ist die quecksilbersäule auf fast 45
grad gestiegen
es ist eine wirklich heiße extremer
sommer in den usa und viele menschen
sagen natürlich dass auch der
klimawandel daran schuld haben könnte